Phong có ý, nhưng quên lên hợp quốc này một sợ thămột,
cạnh báo hành động các thiệp quốc sự của Mỹ tại phía nên giữa là
đã vi vàng lật pháp của tế và kia thế giới chở nên kẻm ăn toàn hơn
kêu gọi tục đồng quốc tế có tìm nói thông nhất
phản đối việc xưa dụ bú lực
phát biểu tại bác li được
người phân ngôn ra vina, sâm ra sân y cho rằng
trên dịch của Mỹ làm suy yếu người tắt cơ bản của lật của tế
theo đó có cuo ra không được đế gió, quốc sự dụ bú lực nhằm vào toàn vệ lãnh thổ
và được lập chiến trị của giá khác
mà nhìn mạnh lấy khu phải là trên tháng xuân yên quên
mà là hành động về tổ hành như trọng tới tổ chúc ăn những cuối tế
theo Phong có ý những quên việc một cường quốc sự giụ bú lực
giữa thái độ chính quên người đi thông điệp nguy hiểm rằng
kẻ mạnh có thể làm bất cứu điều gì họ muốn
thư đỏ làm ra tâm dụ gió, cho mọi trưa ra
Phong có ý những quên là quốc cũng thẳng điện
thương lai của vinh như rất là phải gió chính người ra nước này của định
kèng báo bất ôn và quân sự hoa sẻ chỉ kiến tình hình như đạo sổ đi
trước đó, mình đã tiến hành trình dịch bắt giữ thông thông
phần bên như vui là Ninh Quas Madoro
đưa đăng đối mắt với các cáu quốc vỷ sự
tại mình thông qua một trình dịch quên sự gây tránh cái
trong khi phó thông thống nước này đã tuyên thệ làm thông thống lắm thời